so you think you know a lot about
godzilla don't you well let's test your
knowledge did you know that over a span
of seven years from 2014 till 2021 there
have been more godzilla's than ever
before
there are 25 forms species and types of
godzilla's that have appeared in movies
and shows over these past few years
that is if we clump together the closely
related species of the g-man his various
iterations in the movies his evolving
forms and the meccas
so let's get down with this sickness but
before that be sure to subscribe and
ring that bell icon
let's start with the monster verse
number one 5416 adam the first one that
was seen was but of a skeleton in the
2014 godzilla movie the first of the
legendary most verse films designated as
5416 adam and later as dagon in the
aftershock follow-up comics this
godzilla was long dead when it was
discovered but it was still more than
300 feet in height
number two godzilla 2014 of course we
get the most of us g-man in his first
ever appearance in the most verse and he
is 108 meters or 355 feet tall and
weighs 90 000 tons he has a stocky built
and sharp jagged dorsal blades with a
blocky face and thick thighs
and also featured an atomic breath
number three godzilla 2019 the g-man of
the master verse got an upgrade for his
return to the monsterverse and now here
in kotm he displays a more muscular
built with a very more prominent chest
and maple leaf like dorsal blades he is
now 119.2 meters or 393 feet tall and
weighs almost a hundred thousand tons
number four burning godzilla yes he is
the same godzilla from the kotm movie
but here in this form he also has the
essence of mothra and an overload of
thermonuclear energy he is of a burning
form looking like a mix of lava and high
radioactivity he can discharge nuclear
pulses which vaporizes ghidorah and
miles and miles of buildings
number five godzilla 2021 the g-man in
the movie godzilla vs kong shared many
similar traits with the kotm version he
is kind of different though since he
always looked kind of supercharged
especially when firing the atomic breath
his entire body glows blue and he now
weighs an astonishing 164 thousand tons
number six mega gojira seen in godzilla
vs combed merely as a skeleton in the
throne room of the kongs the species of
godzilla was already dead a long time
before kong came back to the hollow
earth science estimates for this
gigantic specimen ranges from 500 feet
to 1000 feet at the least
number seven doug or the hollow earth
lizard it is believed to be an offshoot
species of the titanic's gojira
evolutionary lineage in the art book
godzilla vs kong what will fall the art
of the ultimate battle royale with the
lizards jacket dorsal blades and skin
texture showing us evidence of a shared
ancestry with godzilla
number eight mechagodzilla it was a 450
feet tall mecha kaiju constructed by
apex cybernetics as an anti-titan weapon
designed to reclaim humanity's place as
the apex predator species it was
designed to kill godzilla it had a
skeletal mechanized look and has a more
powerful beam called the proton scream
number 9 shin the first form now we come
to shin godzilla the movie the first
form only reveals its tail briefly at
the start of the movie it's huge and in
terms of appearance resembles the second
form stale it lacked the physical and
physiological prerequisites to survive
on land its size is estimated to be 14
meters or 46 feet long number 10 shin
the second form the second form
resembles a more eel or a frilled shark
with a long body neck and tail as well
as stubby underdeveloped hind legs for
land mobility and stops on the chest
that appear to be under developed arms
this one is 28 meters or 92 feet tall
and 122 meters or 400 feet long
number 11 shin the third form
in terms of looks godzilla's third form
is similar to the previous incarnations
this form is bipedal with stronger more
developed hand limbs its four limbs are
short and its neck is long in comparison
to its body this form is 57 meters or
187 feet tall and
168.25 meters or 552 feet long
number 12 shin the fourth form
godzilla's fourth form here resembles
other traditional ones in that it is
fully bipedal has a fully grown row of
dorsal spines and is taller the formed
skin is considerably darker black tone
with red glowing highlights it is 118.5
meters or 288 feet tall and 333 meters
or 1100 feet long
number 13 shin's fifth form
godzilla's fifth form resembles a human
with dorsal plates that look like
godzilla's but growing up their spines
models of it demonstrate that they lack
eyes another big cranial division runs
down their backs this fifth form is 15
meters or 50 feet tall number 14 mega
godzilla from ready player 1. in the
movie ready player 1 of 2018 we see the
incarnation of the g-man as this metal
doppelganger mechagodzilla this mecca
was 30 meters or 100 feet tall and
displays a very different look being
dinosaurin as well as steampunk elements
with it with straight dorsal plates
number 15 godzilla ps3 godzilla also
appeared in the playstation 3 game and
featured many gameplays where he
supposedly in a god destruction mode and
has to kill opponents and bosses along
the way he appears as the heisei version
and was 100 meters or 328 feet tall
number 16 snow godzilla in shinkansen
henke robo shinkali on the movie the
marvelous fast alpha x that comes from
the future snow godzilla is a giant
creature who inhabits in another
dimension it looks like a cross between
the heisei and shin godzilla and was
118.5 meters or 388 feet tall
number 17 godzilla phillies now we come
to the anime trilogy godzilla phillies
appearance is exactly like godzilla
earth when it first appeared however
certain traits differentiate from the
latter in aspects of the chin and
beardless looks as well as being 50
meters or 164 feet tall
number 18 godzilla earth the biggest
ever version looks like he has exposed
musculature over his entire body however
this godzilla deviates from looking like
pure muscle and instead bears more of a
likeness towards the roots and the box
of plants godzilla earth is more than
300 meters or 1000 feet tall and three
times as long the biggest ever
19 mega godzilla from that anime this
mecca had a very different look than his
predecessors with a very distinct head
his eyes were crimson but default and
blade-like material and his dozer plates
were nearly crystal-like in appearance
and a mix of white and spiked spine
parts it was 50 meters or 164 feet tall
20 godzilla equatless now we come to the
netflix series godzilla singular pine
godzilla quarterless in his first form
has an elongated aquatic reptile
physiology similar to whales and mosses
like mossosaurus and tylosaurus as well
as the kaiju titanosaurus he is easily
more than 100 meters long
21. godzilla amphibia godzilla
amphibious strongly resembles a baron
when crossed with godzilla in this form
his tail now has three barbs instead of
a slate thin while his hind legs are
smaller than his four legs his feet are
flat and spread apart he is also of the
same length but taller
22. godzilla terrestris godzilla
terrestris takes on the appearance of a
regular godzilla with gorosaurus-like
traits his skin is turquoise in color
with a yellow underbelly and he has an
extended face with a huge lower jaw and
eye situated very near to the snout of
his head he is 30 meters or 100 feet
tall
number 23 godzilla ultima as his fourth
form godzilla ultima from singular point
goes back to the early shower era
featuring a more monstrous version of
the terrestris form a deep charcoal
coloration and white dose dosa blades
the design also features an array of
jagged teeth he was 100 meters or 328
feet tall in this form in the end of the
series
24. robo godzilla this creature first
appears under construction in the post
credit scenes for the final episode of
the first season of godzilla singular
point its frame was built from a
godzilla skeleton found from the 1950s
the size of it is yet unknown
and 25 the showa godzilla from the 2021
short movie this godzilla is the shower
version brought back to life in a touhou
short film godzilla vs hidora this
godzilla about the pollution monster and
won the fight so he would be like the
earlier version around 50 meters or 164
feet tall
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one
take care fam
you